[Music]
zoe kravitz and channing tatum across
the pond enjoying a casual stroll
i love london so much the stars who have
been dating since at least august walk
hand in hand in london clearly enjoying
the sunshine on easter sunday channing
rocks a brown button-up jacket and khaki
colored pants while zoey wears a gray
turtleneck sweater underneath a blue
overcoat i'm really blessed man booked
and blessed is more like it
channing is in the uk filming magic
mike's last dance the third and final
movie in the film's franchise
we're gonna go big i mean truly we're
not gonna we're not gonna leave anything
you know on the bench we're taking it
out we're putting it on stage it's gonna
be it's gonna be wild we're gonna i was
like why are we gonna make a third one
if if not just go really really really
for the stars you know the ever
expanding magic mic brand now includes
live shows always feels silly to say but
it's not easy
to give a lap dance and a reality
competition series
is being sexy always hurt this much i'm
afraid of you guys now plus zoe and
channing are mixing business with
pleasure with the actor starring in
zoe's upcoming directorial debut [ __ ]
island the news comes on the heels of
channing's first go behind the camera
directing and starring in the feel-good
flick dog
right no no no no
no you're just a demon you're just a
demon i know you gave zoey some advice
on it too is that what you said to her
like don't do both yeah well i i just
don't think you enjoy it like i think i
didn't enjoy i didn't get to enjoy
really directing and i just i i think
that
it's
you need twice the time if you're going
to be in the movie and when et spoke
with zoe shortly after seems like she
heard channing's message loud and clear
i'm absolutely not starring in in that
film i i don't i it's hard enough to to
act on on your own i don't know how
people do both so
um yeah i will not be in the movie i'll
just be directing it one thing at a time
it's a big year for zoe who kicked off
2022 by stepping into the iconic role of
catwoman
you got a lot of cats i have a thing
about strength
channing and zoe's step dad jason mamoa
were on hand at the premiere cheering on
their girl and i love to see all the
hype you're getting on social media it
is well deserved of course i'm talking
about jason and channing two of your
guys and your fam giving you a shout out
what does it mean to have them in your
corner giving you that support well you
know we're in new york tonight and i
live here i have a lot of friends and
family here tonight so i feel very lucky
to have a lot of people who love me
[Music]
you